est ce qu'on a vu une jeune femme bio
phobique des cafards devenir une star
grâce à evelyne thomas
non mais ah oui bravo est question de
voir si vous êtes capables puisque vous
avez dansé qu'un cafard vous avais dit
le mot cafard de voir de vrais cafard
non non je vous jure que je ne peux pas
c'est je suis venu c'est pour s'offrir
ok je suis pas venu c'est pour s'offrir
au cas c'est moi qui ai vu qui voulait
faire cette émission et je leur dis
surtout pas de bidonnage rien bien sûr
et à cette nana nous sort un truc
complètement incongrues qui est devient
virale sur la toile et je me suis dit
c'est pas même moi j'étais bluffé juste
pas possible on peut pas être phobies et
après je me suis dit bon si les invités
riches c'est pas bien et il ne triche
pas chez moi mais je me suis dit bon on
va tester ma propre peau vie et je me
suis fait nautiz et sur le plateau parce
que j'étais phobique des souris away et
je les fais jeu comme celle-ci
d'étrangers sont vides des souris je
suis allé à euro disney tout eh bien
c'est mon choix encore une fois qu'il
aura tu ne seras plus faux bilans serait
que vous avez fait alors je me suis fait
parce que moi l'hypnose je la pratique à
titre personnel avec des hypno
thérapeutes pas d'hypnose de spectacle
et je me suis on m'a mis dans un état
d'hypnose
je me suis conditionné mentalement et
finalement j'ai failli j'ai fini par
surmonter je ne me croyait absolument
pas mais j'ai fini par comprendre que
effectivement c'était juste un animal
qui est en face de moi j'ai même réussi
à toucher la souris mais elle m'a mordu
le doigt donc les saignées ah oui donc
je n'étais pas contente après la souris
mais finalement bon eh bien allez là ce
soir
allez merci